welcome to this presentation about
reinforcement learning
um we are going to talk about uh
offline enforcement learning in
particular what's possible to achieve
with the linear predictors from
exponential lower bounds to polynomial
upper bounds
first of all what is offline
reinforcement learning
well
[Music]
you might be more familiar with online
reinforcement learning in online
reinforcement learning
which is the standard reinforcement
learning setting
there is an interaction between an agent
and an environment the agent submits
submits action to the environment and he
receives next states and rewards
in the offline reinforcement learning
setting we assume that this interaction
has already occurred and we are given a
data set
of
state action rewards and next states
and then the data set we are going to
give it to the batch algorithm and then
we are going to ask questions to the
batch algorithm a typical question could
be for example to extract from the data
set and you have optimal policy there
could be other
tasks for example you can do
policy evaluation you can ask to
evaluate the value of another policy but
for this talk we are going to focus on
extracting and your optimal policy
now
we are going to consider the function
approximation setting
in particular we are going to assume
that
the
action value function
can be represented linearly
as an inner product between a feature
extractor that you do know and some
parameter that is unknown to you and
you're trying to
figure out the parameter
there are
two parts
of this talker one is a
fundamental information theoretic lower
bounds
which might be surprising if you're
familiar with the
you know statistical learning component
and then we are going to see what's
possible to do if you have some extra
assumption that is
i would say
another reinforcement of my living
assumption particular bellman closure
and we are trying to see we will try to
see what's possible to achieve under
those additional assumptions
so lower bounds
it turns out that
realizability is insufficient
in reinforcement learning
in particular
let's place ourselves in
in the best possible case so let's
assume
we have no approximation error the
actual mdp
has an exact linear representation for
the optimal action value function
uh we are in the well specified case we
are given
a data set that is very explorative in
particular it does cover in future space
pretty much every direction
and we are going to give you as much
data as you want
even in the limit of infinite data
now
if you're doing uh if you're trying to
just fit a linear predictor
uh in machine learning you know the
answer here is trivial there is no
problem i can
um
i can recover the value of the test data
in reinforcement learning unfortunately
well it depends what you're modeling and
if you're modeling
the action value function unfortunately
the problem turns out to be extremely
complicated
and
you can show a fundamental information
to vertical lower buttons
that says that even if you have this
very strong assumption um perfect
realizability normal specification
infinite data
very good conditioning still you can
find a class of mdps where you can learn
very very little why is this even
happening
well it's happening because
somehow you can
put some sort of neural network into
your mdp
and the dynamics can be very complicated
and the actual value function ends up
being linear but in reality it is
concealing a very complicated object
which is in fact a neural network so
this is not enough for learning we have
to add some extra assumption
now if you take a look at the rld
showdown you're going to see
a bunch of different assumptions we're
going to make one that is very
reasonable batman closure i am now going
to
go into the details of these but this is
slightly stronger than
realizability
under visa you can start asking
interesting questions for example what
happens
if i don't have a very good covariance
matrix for example what happens if i
don't have a lot of data in a certain
direction which might be uh which might
happen to be the direction of the
optimal policy what happens if i of
course have you know a finite amount of
data
and maybe those data
they're being generated by some
adversarial procedure right maybe even
maliciously
well under those conditions we are able
to create an algorithm that can find
a very good policy with high probability
and he scales with the standard
writer some quantity divided by square
root of
n is the amount of samples and c
represents
the
um i would say the cont the conditioning
that you have about your problem and
this is just something specific to the
data set
let's delve a bit more into the
algorithm what's the goal what's the
setting and what's the intuition for it
um
well the setting is that we're going to
give some data set to the bas algorithm
and we ask
the algorithm to return
a policy as good as possible but with
very high probability so we want to be
sure
that the policy that is returned by the
algorithm performs as advertised by the
algorithm let me make a concrete example
to understand the formulation
concrete example is this
we have two policy
two policies a and b
and we want to find the best one to
return we have some available data we
are going to
compute for example the empirical
average of the return
and we want to return the one that is
highest
but just knowing some empirical leverage
is not going to be enough because this
could be widely uh inaccurate so
second thing that we could do is try to
construct some confidence interval with
high probability with the probability
that you specify as input to your
algorithm
and then you can start reasoning with
those
and you could say hey i really want to
be confident about what i return
and so i return a
policy a because sure it has a lower
empirical mean but i am way more
confident in particular in a world case
scenario the performance of policy is
going to be better than the performance
of policy b
now if you spend 2-3 minutes thinking
about this problem which is very simple
i have just two actions
you will realize that i am solving
really a maximum problem i am trying to
find the
the better alternative between a and b
and i am trying to see what's the worst
case uh
outcome
for the alternative uh that they choose
now you can think about this in the
sequential settings in the reinforcement
learning setting
and that's what we do for for the world
we extend that intuition and
we design an algorithm that is able to
pessimistically predict the value of
different policies
and that's what we call a critic
and then we're going to couple it with
an actor and the actor is going to
maximize over the policies
and
this is you know it has a nice framework
because
the critic is really trying to be
adversarial compared to the actor and it
is using the data set
and it is trying to
um
provide pessimistic evaluation to the
policy that is selected by the actor and
so this is a classical you know
adversarial
objective function and what's the right
tool to use for the maximization well
any algorithm essentially from
online learning here we use a
mirror the center
and
the whole procedure is what we call
an actor critic method in reinforcement
learning
and so in terms of main results
we
discovered that really after critic
are a very natural way to solve the max
mean problem in reinforcement learning
and somehow they are the natural
approach
to um
for learning from offline data in a very
robust way
the procedure that we have happens to be
mini max optimum it is computationally
tractable
and um it has a bunch of other
interesting things
uh more you know future directions
well here we examine the linear setting
it would be nice to uh take a look at
this and see what happens with more
general function approximations
another technical question could be
can we do the exploration counterpart
can we try to leverage some of this idea
in the exploration setting where i have
to collect the data myself
and can i try to relax some of these
assumptions that we make in
offline reinforcement learning
and with this i conclude and i thank you
for your attention
okay time for one quick question while
angel sets up
yeah
so
i think i missed one part so this uh
maximum formulation you use it as your
benchmark or it's just a strategy to
actually reach a more
canonical benchmark for a rainforest on
learning it is uh basically the starting
point of the algorithm
so we use it for constructing
we solve this problem okay but the
guarantee is not in terms of this
objective is it
the guarantee
is going to be in terms of this
objective yes you have to you know
implement these things somehow right and
so you have to speak about confidence
intervals but
yes
it will be in terms of visual stuff
next up is angela